Focusing on problems turns you into an expert in what's wrong.
To become an expert in what's right, you have to start thinking about solutions.
A helpful question to Alex would be...
..."Let's just suppose that something happened and you had all the confidence you needed."
"What would you be doing differently?"
"I'd have the courage to be honest with my team when giving appraisals."
"I'd be able to say what I really think in meetings."
"I'd be speaking at conferences and enjoying it."
Now that Alex has a picture of how he'd like to be, he has something to work towards.
This novel way of turning things upside down is called the solutions focus.
Instead of emphasizing what's wrong,...
"Why didn't you meet this month's sales target?"
Solutions talk encourages people to think about what's right.
"Well done for selling five Insurance policies last month!"
"How did you manage that?"
"What did you do?"
People have all the resources they need to make their solutions happen.
Some of those resources are inside them, like previous experiences...
...and others lie within easy reach like support from other people.
It's all about building on success.
If something works, do more of it.
And if something isn't working, do something different.